bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour
cette édition spéciale du 20h en direct
de lives en ukraine nous sommes sur le
parvis de la gare de lille il ya
quelques instants les sirènes ont
retenti nous avons dû nous réfugier dans
un des souterrains de la gare l'alerté a
été levée il ya quelques minutes à peine
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue sur
le plateau de cette émission nous sommes
ensemble pour trois heures de direct
vous en avez l'habitude 19e jour de
grève en ukraine c'était 19e matin de
grève de guerre en ukraine en russie
c'est la fin d'un spa g et c'est une
catastrophe pour ses influences eux en
pleurs depuis ce matin le réseau social
est bloqué dans le pays sur décision du
kremlin pour une influence us comme moi
instagram c'est une source de revenus
instagram pour moi c'est simplement
toute ma vie c'est mon âme c'est ce avec
quoi je me réveille je me couche tous
les jours depuis ces cinq futures années
avec des millions d'abonnés au compteur
ces célébrités reçoivent des messages de
soutien mais également beaucoup de
commentaires pour critiquer l'indécence
de leurs réactions elle peut aller en
ukraine instagram fonctionne à bord
[Musique]
d'abord je pense au peuple ukrainien
évidemment victime de l'agression des
manuels poutine mais le peuple
[Rires]
il est désormais possible d'acheter des
chaussettes à l'effigié des candidats à
cette élection présidentielle
sept candidats ont cet honneur anne
hidalgo yannick jadot marine le pen
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon
valérie pécresse eric zemmour ou à
l'origine il y avait huit paires proposé
mais des chaussettes christiane taubira
a finalement été retiré de la course au
dernier moment alors oui c'est une
démarche commerciale même si la marque
insiste les chaussettes c'est comme le
vote c'est utile allez voter dit la
marque mais c'est quand même très
heureux la perle moi quand je donne à
manger quand mes enfants étaient plus
petits je leur donnais à manger j'étais
bien contente de savoir que c'était des
produits français et pas des produits
dont je ne savais pas tout à fait
comment ils avaient été cultivés il n'y
avait qu'elle produise avaient été
cultivés donc faisons confiance à nos
agriculteurs dont non leur aussi des
revenus dignes et ça c'est un débat à
voir avec la grande distribution qui
parfois à tendance un peu alors serrer
le kiki il faut être honnête
et là ça va ça se passe bien ils disent
plus rien ils sont quelques uns ils sont
contents bah ouais il est bien pas il
s'en est alors pourquoi est-ce que vous
l'aidez pourquoi est-ce que vous
soutenez pas ce qu'il peut se
débrouiller tout seul
je dois l'aider parce que là tu es petit
la mouline je l'aide pour qu'ils aient
une bonne pénétration
à d'accord pour prendre très bien et
vous avez un drôle de métier quand même
mais comment voulez y arriver si on
décide on découvre pas des idées des
calories soin de france plein de
l'abstention et bien on se plaint
d'abstention mais pourquoi les gens ne
voient pas quelque chose de nouveau je
sais foutez de ma gueule
[Rires]
les failli écraser un ancien président
de la république nicolas sarkozy ficelé
passé elle faisait son jogging j'étais
vers une nuit les beaux quartiers oui et
au final j'étais au feu rouge donc le
feu passe au vert j'avance sauf que lui
il arrive en jogging enfin on va faire
son jogging et un débat j'ai pilé devant
lui parce qu'il est passé au feu rouge
oui mais la droite
a fait attention mais j'ai vu j'ai fait
aux minces après j'ai fait un match
c'est en deux temps c'est pas possible
ça l'autoradio marche pas j'ai de la
route à faire je vais au meeting de
reims on va écouter qu'à cela ne tienne
ayouba you buy & you buy ou payet au bye
bye bye et c'est gênant mais quelques
beaux soirs des revenus plus élevés vous
êtes
devenue l'épousé est ce soir c'est dj
forcé qui va passer la soirée avec vous
terre il faut voir mais non mais
attendez attendez la police finit bella
bella
bella à
merci beaucoup merci bon bien sûr là
c'est par où c'est par là c'est balance
et c'est monsieur mélenchon nous sur le
tour doit savoir ont défini la
maintenant je vous accompagne par les
petits jeunes filles en date il ya 12
jours il va me mordre voilà onze ans
dominique mahuet
[Musique]
on n'était pas si
non
robert koehl moore c'est meynard le
masque mosques la plus oubliée et
l'avons plus jusqu'au 24 avril 24 avril
c'est le deuxième tour 24 avril 25 avril
à mon avis le masque est de retour mais
là on est en campagne électorale faut
faire semblant donc qu on nous l'enlève
on nous donne il ya un petit répit bon
pour certains c'est une délivrance
attention c'est terminé pour d'autres ou
déchirement j'ai réfléchi ou plus
continue
le masque n'est plus obligatoire à
l'école dans les commerces et
entreprises et il va falloir se
réhabituer à fermer la bouche ce lundi
signe la fin d'une contrainte mais
peut-être le début de déconvenues une
équipe regroupant les avengers de la
médecine au cnrs université sorbonne
paris institut curie inserm
ils ont mis en évidence les pouvoirs
extraordinaires d'une forme particulière
qu'on appelle formica fut ce cas dans un
domaine extrêmement important c'est
celui de la recherche contre le cancer
on s'est rendu compte que ces fourmis
après un rapide entraînement elles
étaient capables de faire la distinction
entre des cellules humaines normales et
des cellules cancéreuses presque magique
génial c'est génial
moi la culture générale c'est pas mon
truc pourtant j'aime bien l'histoire et
tout ça ça m'intéresse mais retenir
mémoire de poisson je retiens juste la
date où nous mec m'a trompé et pour lui
ressortir dans 40 ans mais alors culture
g 100 m'intéresse sur le moment mais
jamais je vais retenir c'est bon j'ai
bonne mémoire courte ou alors il va
falloir encore un peu de temps un peu
d'argent car entrer des fourmis la saa
coûte un peu d'argent des dizaines de
milliers d'euros je me suis un peu
renseigné les dressages de formule 1
direction los angeles avec une
course-poursuite suivi en direct à la
télévision classique aux états unis sauf
que cette fois l'individu a tenté un
cache cache avec la police
un journaliste à bord d'un hélicoptère
comme en classe
pendant près d'une minute l'homme
recherché pour vol de voiture a bien cru
que son plan allait fonctionner
waouh avant d'être repéré